stratégiques quand il y en a les dépôts
sont pleins donc il faut calmer le jeu
parce que la pénurie à laquelle on
assiste est beaucoup dû aussi un
sentiment de panique malgré malgré vos
alertes d'ailleurs malgré vos alertes en
disant il y en a c'est pas la peine de
vous précipiter bon ok je comprends bien
la stratégie des syndicats ça ne vous
étonnera pas que je ne sois pas d'accord
avec parce que autant manifester autant
contester c'est constitutionnels il y a
aucun problème le blocage qui bloque les
citoyens je ne suis pas pour mais bon ça
ça a toujours été ma position et voilà
après la bataille de l'opinion elle va
elle va se jouer là-dessus moi j'ai déjà
vu des réactions ce matin de gens qui
dans les transports là je vous parle pas
de de l'essence mais dans les transports
disaient bon ça ça commence à suffire
parce que finalement c'est c'est nous
que que vous pénalisez finalement même
si au final ils sont pas forcément pour
le gouvernement c'est parce que je suis
en train de vous dire mais au final les
actions comme ça qui les empêchent qui
entra leur droit de circulation ça les
embête donc voilà c'est tout après vous
savez ce que les syndicats disent ah bah
c'est pas nous c'est à cause du
gouvernement si le gouvernement retire
il y a pas de grève si on était tout à
fait honnête ce serait c'est un c'est
collectivement l'erreur peut-être que je
vous le dis en tant que modèle on aurait
peut-être pas dû faire les choses comme
on les a faites là c'est-à-dire que
peut-être qu'il y avait parce qu'on
regarde on voit ce qui se passe dans le
manifestations croyez pas qu'on soit
sourd loin sans faut ce qu'on voit
surtout c'est que tout ce que tout ce
qui est revendiqué dans la rue c'est ce
qui amène à la retraite bien sûr c'est
pas c'est pas la retraite un peu en
discuter mais ce qui amène à la retraite
et le problème du rapport au travail qui
a changé on aurait peut-être dû
commencer par ça et après faire les
retraites voilà moi je vous dis non on
va poursuivre cette discussion parce que
couper l'électricité dans une dans une
ville complète comme Annonay parce que
le maire de cette commune a été n'est
plus mais a été Olivier du soft vous
croyez sincèrement que pour les
habitants de cette ville dont certains
sont même peut-être membres de votre
Confédération ce soit vraiment quelque
chose de comment dire j'allais dire très
intelligent mais j'arrive pas à trouver
d'autres termes c'est pas c'est pas
vulgaire ce que je dis mais franchement
quelle est l'intérêt sincèrement je vois
pas comment les gens vont comprendre ce
genre de manifestation autant les Robins
des Bois même si j'approuve pas ok des
gens ils comprennent ça parce que ils en
tirent les bénéfices mais là une ville
de un peu plus de 2000 habitants quand
même dont le maire n'est plus Olivier du
socle qui n'a rien à voir avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans le pays
expliquez-moi l'intérêt juste si on fait
si on fait un tout petit peu d'histoire
politique je vous signale que ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui était prédit par un
homme de gauche et pas par la droite
libérale en 1992 il s'appelait il
s'appelle Michel Rocard d'accord qui a
un rapport sur les retraites en 92 avait
annoncé ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
pour une raison simple le facteur
démographique vous n'y pouvez rien plus
d'inactif que d'actifs c'est la loi de
la démographie à partir de ce moment-là
il faut travailler moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord je vous en vous regardant
les yeux je suis tout à fait d'accord
pour qu'on confie moi modem pour qu'on
confie l'étude d'un projet de loi sur
les retraites aux organisations
syndicales d'ailleurs
vous gérez il me semble il me semble
vous gérez paritairement la girco il n'y
a pas de problème c'est un régime
excédentaire c'est un régime par point
que vous avez combattu en 2019 bon
passons mais alors il y a un truc que
vous ne dites pas aux Français c'est que
dans ce régime là vous avez quand même
passé le point de bascule à 64 ans sans
prévenir personne et vous augmentez les
cotisations quand le besoin s'en fait
sentir sans que ça ne fasse de vagues
comment pouvez-vous expliquer aux
Français que pour agir Carco dont ceux
qui touche les pensions de retraite les
salariés du privé ça représente deux
tiers de leur pension de retraite vous
agissez en très bon intelligence pour
maintenir le système à flot et que vous
le refusiez sur le système général pour
moi c'est une immense interrogation je
vous le dis c'est un immense
interrogation et une immense
contradiction bien je veux qu'on vote le
texte
la position est assez claire nous ne
souhaitons pas le 49.3 je veux que le
texte soit voté que les deux assemblées
s'expriment que les Français sachent qui
a voté pour et qui a voté contre que
chacun soit mis face à ses
responsabilités et donc vous-même et
vous le verrez quand je vois le texte
ah oui on est dans sur un enthousiasme
[Musique]
a priori je voterai le texte il y a
aucun problème là-dessus non mais
je vais pas me cacher derrière mon petit
doigt j'ai toujours dit simplement pour
une chose même si je regrette qu'on ait
fait les choses dans le mauvais sens
c'est que cette histoire de financement
de notre système de retraite c'est à
avant tout le problème des recettes et
je l'ai déjà dit sur votre plateau notre
problème c'est un manque de 30 milliards
de recettes par an alors soit on veut
sauver le système par répartition il
faut évidemment revenir à l'équilibre et
ce texte fait partie du retour à
l'équilibre donc en ce sens avec ma
conviction bien évidemment je voterai le
texte mais je souhaite avant tout le
Parlement les deux chambres puissent
s'exprimer ok enfin en responsabilité et
son français et s'il y a 49-3 bah si à
49-3 vous doutez bien qu'on votre APA la
motion censure mais j'envoie un message
très fort au gouvernement et au
président de la nous voulons voter ce
biexiste